الليل لم يكن هادئا على اكثر من جبهه في
اوكرانيا القوات الجويه الاوكرانيه تحدثت
عن توجيه القوات الروسيه نحو 70 ضربه
بصواريخ من الجو والبحر وبمسينات خلال
الليل كان من بين الاهداف وفق الرئيس
الاوكراني مصنع لمحركات الطائرات في
مقاطعه جنوب الشرقي البلاد واهداف غربيه
اوكرانيا لكن في بخموت تبدو محاوله التقدم
الاوكراني متواصله حيث نشر الجيش الروسي
مقاطع فيديو قال انها الاستهداف مواقع
اوكرانيه بالقرب ما ادى الى تراجعها
وتدمير دبابات وعربات مدرعه لكن رئيس
الاستخبارات العسكريه الاوكرانيه قال انهم
يتقدمون في بخموت اسرع من تقدمهم جنوبا
بسبب بناء القوات الروسيه مواقع دفاعيه
كامله التجهيز بشكل عام تحدثت وزاره
الدفاع الروسيه عن شن قواتها هجمات باسلحه
جويه وبحريه بعيده المدى وعاليه الدقه على
مواقع عسكريه اوكرانيه من قواعد الجويه في
غربيه اوكرانيا بينما جاء اعلان كييف عن
اسقاطها نحو 30 صاروخا وسبعه وعشرين مسيره
روسيه وفي مقاطعه قال الجيش الروسي انه
احبطه هجوما كانت القوات الاوكرانيه تحضر
لشنه باتجاه رابوتينا واعلنت الدفاع
الروسيه احباط مواصفاتها محاوله من نظام
كييف لتنفيذ مسمته هجوما ارهابيا بطائره
مسيره على اهداف في منطقه موسكو لكن
اللافته كان ما اعلنته وكاله ريانو
البواليه لروسيا عن تعرض
لضربه ب 12 صاروخا وتم اسقاط تسعه منها
والجسر الطريق امداد رئيسي يربط بين خرسون
وشبه جزيره القرم وتسبب قصفه في تضرر خط
انابيب الغاز الذي يمر بالقرب منه وضمن
مؤشرات التصعيد اعلن حاكم العثور على رغم
بحري على بعد 100 متر من شاطئ لوبين كوفو
في شبه جزيره
عن السلطات المواليه لروسيا قولها ان
القوات الاوكرانيه استخدمت ذخائر عنقوديه
في قصف مبنى جامعي في المدينه في حين نشر
الرئيس الاوكراني صوره لمركز لنقل الدم في
بلده كوبيانس شرقيه استهدف وفقه بقنبله
روسيه
الاخيره لن تقدم لروسيا شيئا وفق تعبيره
استهدف هجوم صاروخي روسي اخر بلدنا اليوم
استخدمت فيه صواريخ كينجر وكاليبر لضرب
مصنع موتور سيتش ومنطقه
اسقطنا بعض الصواريخ بفضل جنود الدفاع
الجوي لكن بغض النظر عن عدد الهجمات
الروسيه فانها لن تقدم للعدو شيئا حرب
اخرى هذه المره على الجبهات الالكترونيه
عبر الطائره المسيره وهذا ما نقلته صحيفه
واشنطن بوست عن عمل واحده من القوات
الخاصه الاوكرانيه تسمى الفا وتوجيهها
الطائرات بدون طيار لضرب اهداف روسيه مع
تعطل قدره الروس على التشويش عليها سلاح
تبدو اهميته كبيره للاوكرانيين في ظل
الدفاعات الروسيه المحصله التي تعطل سير
هجومهم المضاد